we do quite a lot of like the team
building so it's not just about like i
think we speak before about like the
busy culture that can be associated with
recruiting you know like we'll go on
nice like team walks and just talk about
stuff that isn't about recruiting so i
think naturally you know we are
conscious of who we employ and actually
we're getting quite a few we do
welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast i'm your host hisham azuz and in
this week's episode i was joined by the
founders of mariah talon emma crabtree
and nikki den i absolutely love their
passion and energy for their business
they're two years into their own journey
before working for multiple brands
before they started their own and they
are extremely passionate about
founder-led businesses getting more
women in direct positions and leadership
positions and they have big plans for
their company enjoy the episode emma
nicky welcome to the podcast thank you
thank you thank you so much for coming
down i was just saying
i'm pretty sure you're both the the
first northerners to be in the the new
studio space
so thanks for coming down
um
so as as you all know the sort of place
where i would like to start this is the
million pound question
and i'm sure you thought even more about
it since starting your own business yeah
so and i'm going to come to you first
but i'd love to hear your thoughts your
take on what you believe are the sort of
common characteristics and traits that
really make up a successful recruitment
consultant in today's market
i think the main three are belief
relentlessness and an innate desire to
succeed basically okay all those three
together the others go with it obviously
but they're the main three drivers i
think it's a belief yeah belief as in
like belief in yourself yeah absolutely
like you can do it you know we never
going out into recruitment or the
business yeah thought we'd fail that's
just not an option yeah yeah yeah i
think that's what makes us successful
because we have that belief yeah it's a
passion to keep yourself driving towards
what your kind of angles are supposed at
the very beginning
where where's where's that come from i
have no idea
i generally have i think i'm an
optimistic person so that helps but i
really don't know where it comes from
yeah i really don't i think when i first
started in recruitment i kind of didn't
believe i could do it almost so i think
for me it's as i've kind of like tried
to succeed i suppose the beliefs come
along with it yeah
so obviously as as we sort of have
spoken stuff before we did this like
we'll we're going to talk a bit about
both of your journeys working for other
companies and then the main focus that
we're going to talk about is this sort
of two-year journey that you you've both
been on yeah um so i guess like where
where i was like to start is like nikki
who who were you before recruitment
would you say well before recruitment
then so i was a trainer actually a
trainer yeah so in a call center so i
started in salford university graduated
from there ended up living in manchester
and i was working in a call center and i
thought right okay i want to try and do
something different so i just started
applying for jobs internally at the
corporate insurance society so i ended
up being a trainer so got that position
and i was doing savings and investments
to start with to be fair and then they
outsourced the whole of that department
so my first day as a trainer i was given
like a microphone and stood at a podium
and got told to go and train motor and
home insurance to agree full of 30
people yeah so it was pretty on top to
do that but you know that that's the
thing all those types of things that
build you you know give you a bit of
confidence but yeah it was a bit
daunting to start with and then i did
that for like maybe two three years and
then unfortunately they got rid of quite
a lot of people and so i was maybe
dungeon and i just bought myself like a
flat in congratulations i know exactly
and then literally just as like the
recession was starting because 2008 and
and then yeah i just made started making
applications and started in recruitment
and yeah i went for a few different
companies and then ended up in in a
place in winslow yeah attack
did you was you aware of recruitment
then as a career or like a typical okay
yeah i know it was absolutely nobody
even spoke about it to be quite honest
so there was actually a girl that said
you're quite chatty you're like
you could be good
and yeah they just said you'd be good at
recruitment so i'd actually apply to a
different company and then they
forwarded my cva to someone that they
knew because it was closer to home and
what what about you emma who who would
you say how would you describe yourself
before recruitment where was your outfit
well i got into recruitment quite late i
was 29. really yeah yeah yeah because i
left uni yeah went to new york for a bit
had a travel bug then decided i wanted
to teach english because that would
allow me to live abroad so i did that in
london and then i moved to japan and it
was supposed to be for a year but it was
for six amazing years i always find that
fascinating yeah that you did that it
was amazing but then it got to a point
in my life at 29 like right i don't want
to teach english i'm coming back to
england i have had money there yeah i
had a good lifestyle yeah but what am i
going to do in england you know so i
started applying to marketing jobs
because that's what i did at uni
like 20k in london with slow career
progression opportunities so i thought i
needed something else and a couple of my
friends were in recruitment
everyone in japan is now in tech
recruitment by the way really yeah yeah
so and they were like apply so i just
replied to one place got a call had the
interview met nikki yeah at the
interview
yeah
and then stayed there for a bit and
absolutely loved it yeah yeah i love
that so
like what what's what's the korean
recruitment given by a few then that
maybe you least expected you know like
it's exactly that it's a career like i
didn't know i was going to be any good
at it yeah i didn't know yeah i didn't
know how long i'd be doing it for i'd
kind of got made redundant i had a flat
you know mortgage and then started on
this journey and yeah i mean i was at
the first company i worked for like
nearly 13 years and you just never
really thought of that as gonna be like
a full-blown career yeah that's probably
what it gave me to be there what about
you yeah same career to be proud of
absolutely really yeah and i always had
like a business mind as well
so kind of from there knew i wanted my
own business started in recruitment
thought i'm quite good at this so
that's what i'll do one way yeah yeah
exactly did you so like when both of you
met for the first time was there like a
spark straight away i don't know did you
like just get on like a house on fire or
nick you really wanted me to get that i
knew really honestly like when you
interview somebody and you know that
they're going to be great like emma was
amazing in the whole interview process
look if she's got to get the job yeah
and other managers weren't is key or
what i don't know nikki was like say
this say that i was like
got it
really well she did a great job
i love that so so basically so nikki you
so you worked um
in different bands for like was it like
12 years or so yeah exactly before you
started mariah and then emma for you it
was was it more like two three years it
was or was that three yeah three four
yeah yeah yeah
nice so i guess nicki what i really want
to ask you and stuff before we get on to
both of you starting this business is
a lot of people listen to this podcast
because they want to progress quickly
they want a successful career obviously
you like you said maybe you didn't
expect it at the time but you went on
this amazing journey and going from
joining at that point to them becoming
like a divisional manager by the time
that you left
what obviously people want to know like
how
how would what do you do differently to
get those opportunities because
obviously recruitment's competitive
internally just as much externally so
what do you think what are some of the
things that you did well that enabled
you to to progress your career do you
think definitely i mean i was always a
planner i always made sure that you know
i knew exactly what i was going to be
doing the next day you know you'd go
through what you need your objectives
throughout the course of the day and
just make sure you tick them off and you
made a plan for the next day
um and yeah i mean i think in terms of
like i asked for a lot of promotions as
well you know like i just went it sounds
simple but like yeah a lot of people
don't ask you've got to ask yeah exactly
and i think that's that's a big thing
you can get forgotten unless you
actually put yourself forward sometimes
and but yeah i'd probably say yeah just
asking for what you want really yeah and
obviously delivering like doing what you
need to be doing in your role absolutely
but when you say like just just talk to
us a bit about that for a second so when
you say ask are we literally saying like
hey i've absolutely smashed my target
this year like what like how can i move
like what did that ass look like yeah i
need to be honest it was probably a
little bit uncomfortable sometimes
because you have to put yeah yeah you
know you've got to basically put
yourself in a position where you're
going in and say look i know i've
achieved this i know who these
objectives i want to be a manager of a
team you know i'm already doing mace the
job so this is what i'd like to be able
you know like the title and like the pay
rise to go with it
as well so yeah i did ask a lot for that
and then and then emma what about you so
like how would you describe your sort of
early is in recruitment did you sort of
get like get into it straight away like
i don't know how would you describe your
early years then yeah well early years
about 29 yeah and everyone else around
me i was only
18k learning more
and everyone else around me was a lot
younger and i was like i need to be like
nikki very soon yeah you know that's all
i used to think like when people used to
go an interview or go to the boardroom
and meetings i was like i want to be
doing whatever yeah how do i get to that
level so i just wanted the money was
great but for me i wanted the career i
wanted to be a manager i wanted to lead
a team so i think it was that hunger and
pressure that i put on myself because
the age was at and my one goal was to
like put a deposit down in house in the
first year
yeah so let's just talk about that
because i think that is interesting and
i think people
because i think like typically a typical
recruitment company will
try and hire young people maybe grads
whatever and yeah like you said for a 29
year old although that that isn't old i
mean i'm 29 this month like that that
isn't old in my eyes
some because i think i think obviously a
big part of what we're trying to do this
podcast is like
recruitment should absolutely be a
career that people choose rather than
falling into so yeah i guess it'd be
good because i did think that oh that
must have been quite challenging to look
around and go [ __ ] how this person's
younger than me so what what maybe
advice would you give to sort of people
entering recruitment who are maybe a bit
older as to like maybe things to be
mindful of and why it's something that
they should absolutely consider and not
think oh i've missed my chance because
i'm yeah you know it's not too late in
any career to change and i really admire
those who do that because it's brave to
do and it's almost like a relationship
you know you can be in a job and you're
like oh i'm 30. it's okay
you know i'm earning money i need to be
sensible i want a mortgage but really
you've got such a long life ahead of you
and we only live once yeah so do you do
what you want to do yeah and i
absolutely love it i never i wouldn't
change anything yeah i love that so
let's let's go into let's go into both
of you obviously going on on this
business journey
so um i guess talk to us a bit about so
when when did you found the company when
did things start
it was february well kind of the idea
was in february 2020 yeah but we
actually launched april 2020. yeah yeah
just after caving
the first week of lockdown we launched
yeah yeah okay that was cool that was
great fun so i'm excited to unpack this
so obviously just to frame it up for
people so basically you've been going
for two years now
just recently had a really cool rebrand
and you also to kick kick off this
journey you decided to go down the
investment route right so so why don't
why don't we start there because i think
that would be really interesting for
people to hear so one
what what drew you towards or like what
like
how did you come to the decision of like
you know what actually going down the
investment route and having that help at
the beginning is something actually we
really want to go for and there's
something that we align with and can be
helpful yeah i mean it came from an
unfortunate conversation really a
fortunate conversation with a rec direct
yeah because when i was looking to leave
where i was yeah i was like
and she was like you sound like you want
your own business
yeah i think i do
but i was like how do i do that i've
never had a business i wouldn't know
where to start
and she was like i know someone right so
very yeah fortunate because she then
introduced me to mark nealon who's
investor of recruitment companies so we
kind of hit it off obviously had a lot
of conversations and
and then yeah did you go into the i know
it probably felt quite organic at the
time but in hindsight was it any i know
you said you hit your mark hit it off
but was there anything that
maybe you was mindful of to that you
wanted to see or pick up on the
would i guess give you more confidence
or feel more comfortable in potentially
having someone like mark an investor
involved from the start well i think his
track record because he hadn't done it
you know he um formed or was a director
of its successful company
and then i met people that he'd already
invested in so straight away they're
like he's great and had about
conversations with five people so
instantly you feel at ease yeah yeah
yeah he puts you in touch doesn't he
with other businesses yeah yeah
yeah
yeah and then when and then when how did
you when did uh you and nicky then start
having these conversations like how did
that
i
happen
of engineered my own interview yeah
really yeah
well i would i'd gone to a different
company and it wasn't really working out
so i'd i'd actually recommended emma
speak to the rector act that had
introduced her tomorrow right
you both stayed in touch and everything
yeah yeah yeah yeah always so like i'd
kind of thought do you know what i think
what she's up to maybe one a bit of this
as well yeah so i just texted emma and i
was like hey should we go for dinner and
let's have a prosecco and some food yeah
and then i sat down and i was like so
what's this all about it was really
funny though there was other people yeah
yeah we'd literally like sit next to him
tell me about the business
so yeah and that was it and basically
yeah so yeah we spoke to mark and then
we were martin said as well
most businesses apparently there's data
around this are more successful when you
yeah yeah because you're fully prepared
to like just go on your journey right
now
yeah i was just like let's do this
then i was like somewhere along the
route yeah and it's great as well
because we've obviously been friends
since we've left
it with a friend yeah yeah yeah
obviously you've built trust right and
sometimes that if you've got that from
the very beginning yeah you've built
that relationship we know how we work as
well that's why it's important yeah like
we share the same values and we know
what we liked and didn't like about
where we've worked previously and it's
nice to share experiences with someone
else isn't it rather than doing it by
yourself a bit of a soundboard as well
you know because you have a lot of ideas
and it's like what do you think and you
know you get you gain so much more when
you're able to share something i think
so
let's just focus on this for for a
second and so what would you say because
we're now like two years in
what would you say have been some of the
like two free core things that you think
because you've had mark's support from
the very beginning it's it's enabled you
to do or what's been really helpful
because i think people a lot of people
listen to this will maybe think one day
they don't have their own recruitment
company
obviously there's a lot of people
businesses now that will be trying to
message people say hey have you thought
about starting a recruitment company we
can help you so what would you say have
been like the the really sort of core
things that mark's really been able to
help with out of interest he's helped
with everything hasn't he really you
know just operationally you know like we
were great at what we did and you know
you can be a good recruitment consultant
and a manager but you know when you're
looking at the business as a whole you
know that's the areas it just gives you
so much support with so you know just
looking at day-to-day operations how can
you streamline things and so yeah he's
given us trends as well and networking
as well really sure yeah he's introduced
to some amazing people yeah um so yeah
that's the thing about mark and he
really champions that the idea of
meritocracy yeah so it's the best idea
wins not where it comes from so he's
like trust me but go and ask someone
else yeah you know why try and do it
yourself when there's a million people
out there who've done it made mistakes
and can tell you and like help you along
the way so yeah provides a lot of that
yeah and he's just you know and it's
just someone if you're like oh god what
do we do yeah give him a call
yeah he's like yeah great support really
supportive yeah so and then so and then
a couple of last things because people
be interested you don't have to go into
like the exact like details but like how
how was it structured out of interest
like was it like i don't know so mark
had x percentage of the company and if
both of you hit certain goals and that
gets reduced like because this is the
stuff that people like how like do they
have the majority share of my business
like how did you how was that structured
if you don't mind yeah we have the
majority share yeah it's very fair
because a lot of people were saying to
me that's what i mean yeah oh my god
yeah like all your business yeah do you
report into him it's nothing like that
so we have majority share and you know
there was a loan at the start which we
paid back very quickly but for us it's
not the financial support yeah it's he's
an angel investor and a coach yeah so
every week we speak to him and it's
amazing and we strategize and we talk
about ideas and so it's that element
that we'd want to keep forever you know
yeah so yeah we can reduce his share
options as well in time yeah yeah yeah
so he's very fair like that no i love
the fact that it's actually not about
the capital it's about because you
didn't mention that once it was the
network it was the people you've been
speaking to
yeah um and i think more and more people
i speak to now young young recruiting
entrepreneurs like they're just way more
humble and willing to ask for help so
people might get a year down the journey
two year and go i don't know all the
answers so i wanna help and if you
of you've got someone that
can help but also has got skin in the
game and it's in their interest for both
of you too
to improve this business then that's a
great relationship the worst thing you
can have is an ego yeah because we don't
know why pretend we know how to run a
business we're getting the idea now yeah
but you know in the early days like why
try and do it by selling yeah you know
because we're we're not the best at that
we want to be the best at that and
that's the journey we're on so from and
then last point then so from the the
beginning then was there like um
did you did you speak every week or was
it like quarterly board meetings or like
what was the typical structure
oh my god
what is going on in the world
my kitchen table with bobby like mark i
didn't plan on this
and he was really nice through that
because what was funny is he knew
everything like we were like you know
when it first started yeah
we never thought it was going to go on
for long as it did and mark kind of was
like it's like doomsday yeah yeah okay
girls this is going to be bad and we
were like oh my god like
negative never going to happen but he
still believed in us which he could have
freaked out and being like why am i
investing in a company let's park this
for a bit but we had no choice we'd left
our jobs we had nothing else to do but
just push on basically so we're on the
phone a lot
of the early days now it's every we meet
every week yeah go for coffee sit down
it's great to look at longer term plans
as well so that's the thing it's always
about like this is where you could be
girls so yeah it's great so let's just
paint a picture so obviously yes
obviously i had to go on this journey
during the yeah
so like what what did what did the
company look like by the end of year one
then just so we can paint the picture
was it still just you two was a couple
of people when you had an office we
moved into an office in the august yeah
and taken on a couple of people yeah we
hired it yeah so i think we finished at
about four people and an office yeah
yeah so let's just talk about them like
because i mean it all seems like a blur
doesn't it so like
what what do you think
has enabled like what do you think in
hindsight enable both of you to like
actually not it to go oh my god like we
had at the worst possible time like we
failed or i don't know what what what
did you do looking back that you think
enabled you to get to
four people and i'm i'm assuming you're
doing revenues and these things so like
i don't know how did you how you were
able to do that despite the challenges i
don't think we ever really doubted that
it would work to be quite we got some
good deals here yeah actually yeah nikki
did a really good deal first off then i
did one an area i don't usually recruit
for was like
so that kept us going yeah i mean it's
like the sheer joy we really enjoy what
we did and like we said earlier failure
is not an option yeah mirai is going to
make it was always going to make it yeah
it's just that just the belief yeah yeah
absolutely but we enjoy what we do as
well like we love what we do and like we
made it a bit fun as well you know even
though we got to the point like bobby
like my son's seven so he would be like
five at the time or something he'd only
just started school so then he's now sat
at our kitchen table while mummy and
emma are like
cold calling like hey guys should we
work with
bobby's repeating my phone number in the
background he said it that many times
yeah you know and that was it you know
we just had to get on with it yeah to
make good of what we've been given so
and talk to me about the because the
name's interesting
so that was another thing which mark
gave guidance on because i was like ejc
associate
all these like crap names like with my
name and obviously and he was like
i never knew that what about something
that means something a bit more yeah and
then actually as my friend in japan joe
who's amazing i was like right a
japanese name yeah connects with the
recruitment yeah and he was like mirai
because it means future in japanese i
was like nailed it it was the first
thing he said all right mark mirai
love it don't know what it means but
love it
yeah and we do like it yeah and we were
mirai tech recruitment yeah and now
we're just mirror italics
but assume we want to just be miranda
right right yeah so that was the real
brand that you went for yeah um so talk
to me about like i'm sure looking back
it was just like just do anything to to
get deals in make it work but like what
i'm sure might want to help with this
but like you said you've worked to other
companies you'd be able to look at those
experiences i really enjoyed that didn't
enjoy that but like what
a lot of people say want to do things
differently when they start their own
recruitment business so like how how did
both of you
think and execute that you being unique
and different and what did you bring to
the market that you felt that was
different and you
made mirai mirai
i think we were keen to look at like
culture where
mirai and i think that's something that
we will never really forget you know for
us it's all about making an environment
that you know everybody wants to come to
work and they want to enjoy it and i
mean it bounces off the space to our
clients as well we want to make sure
that we're creating like a really good
atmosphere and like building up really
good relationships that's the players
which really thought about the people
the people yeah
until people are happy within the
business yeah
how can they provide good service yeah
and then naturally if you're coming to
work spring in your state yeah the phone
people can tell you know so that's
important so it starts with culture
and our team and then naturally that
extends onto the service we can provide
as well hey everyone a real quick one
from me this podcast would not be
possible without our amazing podcast
partners vincerie and sauce breaker
because you listen to this podcast
you're able to get your hands on
exclusive savings on both of these
award-winning products if you're all a
growing recruitment business you have to
check out vincerie who are an all-in-one
operating system for your growing
recruitment business with sourcebreaker
if you want to make sure that all of
your recruiters have the best tools on
the market to stand out and beat their
competition then you have to check out
sourcebreaker use the link in the show
notes in the comments below and you'll
be able to get yourself exclusive
savings on these amazing products and
then what about like did you did you um
identify and focus on any particular
niches have you like i don't know
involved any of the services you have
like what has that been like that's
maybe impacted the the difference and
the uniqueness as well yeah i think
within tech because a lot of places are
we are tech and that's fine that's great
but we recognize that as it's so
candidate driven we start with the
candidates we look at cloud and data
predominantly
yeah just because like the mad markets
really
um and then yeah and contracts is
something that we didn't do but now
we're looking at a contract first yeah
so we have adapted along the way just
because you have to and what what did
you find because thinking back when you
started like the polar opposite now
where everyone's saying i've got jobs
out coming out my ears and like it's the
candidate pipeline i need help with back
then it was like no one's hiring
what ended up being the most effective
way for you to start winning logos
getting your own clients on board
because that that can typically be
some of the things that people are most
worried about of like bringing them
those clients that are going to be your
first paying customers so like
what ended up really working on that
front i think we went after multi-higher
solutions okay because naturally you
know we put a lot of work in and if you
place a one-man band it manager that's
great but where's the repeat business
yeah and we know we always get repeat
business so okay well that that's not
going to work so let's start targeting
the companies that you do have to chip
away at but eventually it'll pay
dividends because they've got a large
workforce and you become an extension of
them you put the same amount of effort
into
getting one job spec as you would do you
know creating a relationship and
becoming someone's sons like partner
yeah yeah that's interesting
let's just focus on that for a second i
think that'd be interesting so i mean
now you're saying like chip away let's
obviously people
want like practical thoughts or ideas on
like what what's worked and what helps
other people so like when you what has
typically worked time and time again
when it comes to getting into like a
larger account or a growing customer
like what have you found um yeah has
really worked is it going direct to the
hiring manager and building a
relationship is it actually delivering a
really great candidate experience and
then they refer you when they're
internally what has ended up really
working and getting into these bigger
accounts yeah often hiring manager yeah
then falling out with hr
then becoming best friends with hr and
the hiring managers and just really
listening you know i can't stand it when
you hear people i've got 100 candidates
just for it no you don't and that would
make our job very easy if we have a load
of candidates waiting yeah i think
ultimately like just leveling with them
i understand but we're going to take
ownership of your challenges you know we
absolutely buzz off it don't we like
absolutely we're like give us the jobs
we love this you don't like it so give
it to us and i think that people can
tell how much we enjoy what we do
definitely just even in our tone of
voice like okay calm down you can have a
job and still get that same buzz i think
of finding a really good candidate or
you know like pulling a role in with a
new client or something as we would have
done you know like 10 years ago so what
i wanted to ask you both then because i
think as you said earlier like great
there's so many positives of it not just
being one person as both of you
but obviously there can also be
challenges that come with that so
obviously you both had that added
benefit of working with each other so
probably had a bit of an insight but how
have both of you got better at
understanding like right emma you are
way better than this than nikki or
whatever like how just talk to us a bit
about that because i think sometimes
having interviewed people that started
business with two people that can
sometimes be a bit of a journey so how
has that been for both of you i think
our problem in the beginning is we're
both good at the same thing right yeah
so we're so similar you know so my dad
used to be like the best business
partner is when you're good at this
yeah
yeah whereas we're like i'm a little bit
better at finances and systems so i'm
the finance queen
and that's the thing and it kind of was
like i don't know if a guilt thing with
both of us we've tried to do the same
thing so we both went on a demo together
we both had the phone call we're like
why are we both doing this
so now recently we've kind of defined
our roles because you have to think
about because we don't look at candidate
sides anymore but we still do look at
the business but when we step away from
that what are our roles in your business
so you have to look at long term what
are our strengths and what do we enjoy
doing well that's it exactly so we yeah
we have designated rpes for a certain
job it's a responsible people person
yeah exactly so like i'd look at like
more of the training and development and
then and it looks like more of the
marketing stuff so yeah financial system
definitely finance that would be
outsourced
so what was the first step in that just
was it literally like right we we keep
going on the same things like you
noticed it and it's like right we need
to work out if you're doing what you
just find out that you don't do you know
but not enough of one thing see if you
split your time yeah and there's just
there's endless amounts of jobs
obviously in recruitment it never stops
anyway this was another candidate to
call another role to change but when
you've got the operational side as well
you know it can be a bit overwhelming
sometimes so you have to actually just
split your time yeah so was it literally
like your boyfriend in the media room
was like right let's just be honest with
each other what do you enjoy them what
are you better at and then you just
started just we actually did yeah yeah
because we were coming to meetings like
that's not been done
were you gonna do that i know i think i
was gonna do that okay i'll do that yeah
and there was just no process behind it
and now we're like this is this is what
i do yeah that's what you do and it's so
much better isn't it well you do it
properly as well and like it gets yeah
you get a lot more value out of your job
so how do you hold each other
accountable then do you have like is it
weekly things that you then hold each
other accountable for
yeah
we talk a lot about everything we need
to get done we're getting better at
putting things in the diary yeah because
otherwise it doesn't get done yeah and
there's always something to do and we
were guilty of putting things off yeah
when really you just need to get it done
what is important like when you're in
recruitment yeah okay what do we need to
do right i'm gonna and another thing we
were doing is feeling guilty about doing
those tasks in the golden hours yeah but
really it's like we need to do marketing
so i spent last week two days straight
just focusing on that and it felt so
much better that i'm not doing it at the
weekend or yeah evening
yeah so
talk i know it's something you're both
really passionate about talk to me about
what's been your experiences journey in
being in a
female owned business like what what's
that been like has there been maybe
certain challenges that you've had to
navigate or i don't know like talk to me
about it do you know what i i think
because i've always done this job it
doesn't feel that much different to me
okay it's because i've done like the
management side for a while anyway but
yeah i do think there is a massive lack
of females in you know tech and also in
management positions especially around
recruitment um but yeah and there is a
boys club feel yeah
and even like guys we interview they
don't want to be part of the boys
and yeah times have changed that's the
thing and there's a stigma because if
you have a child what do you do then yes
so i think naturally you know we are
conscious of who we employ and naturally
we're getting quite a few people we
don't have a lot of girls
yeah but that we
are ideal as a 50 50 split yeah and
different personalities not the typical
recruiter you might think of as well so
how how do you think we can i guess um
impact
that sort of lean towards like more men
in senior positions and recruitment
companies or just more men overall i
don't know have you i'm sure you've
thought about about this it's going to
help if there's more women in their own
recruitment businesses than men but i
don't know how have you fought about we
can how we can impact that
i don't know if we've made a conscious
effort yeah i think it's more like the
personality that goes with it as well
like big drinking culture
lads club all this we want different
people we don't want many versions of us
we want a real eclectic mix of people
because it's not always a typical
salesperson that succeeds easily
and that is something to think about
actually because you know you stereotype
people you know what's a successful
sales person you know and it's quite a
loud you know outgoing type of person
but you know people that don't actually
have that type of person can be a bit
more subdued or you know a bit calmer
and personality can actually be one of
the best recruiters ever as well you
know so different personalities do you
definitely work
so so let's let's talk about the the
last year then obviously you had your
two year anniversary recently yeah not
yet not quite yet okay sorry april so so
i know i know something sort of i've
known a bit about your business
something that's been quite exciting is
the us piece right yeah so like talk to
me about how that's going when you first
sort of identify that because
i'm sure you've you've noticed i
definitely have like more and more
recruitment companies it seems have
the us on their business plan or they're
doing it currently so talk to me a bit
about that journey so far when did it
start how it's going yeah so i was
actually working with some like uh uk
based sas companies that just wanted to
scale in the us so it was quite organic
we did a couple of a few different
project deployment teams in atlanta and
chicago so we did that because it was
part of their you know uk scaling plans
but yeah i mean in terms of what we want
to do in moving forward it just opens
your eyes up so much and there's so much
opportunity yeah you know it's it's a
great um market to get into
absolutely there's a world out there and
we want to be part of it yeah and like
you said i think i've heard other people
on this podcast say as well it's like
the two-week notice period oh yeah
we focus a lot on senior appointments in
the uk which is great three to six
months notice periods you know and
that's so much happening
and it's just fast-paced and you've done
a sterling job but nothing the hardest
fills them not to take it away from you
it's actually going to breathe in
comparison to uk based yeah hiring um so
you did literally just linkedin
recruiter is obviously your best friend
and yeah you just literally got all your
calls set up and yeah it's been so much
easier so let's just talk about this
then and so you've been typical are you
being the person like driving this
because i'm assuming that your customers
yeah yeah so actually talk a bit about
this for a second so what would you say
have been the main so i'm assuming
previous to that you've always worked in
what the uk europe market predominantly
yeah say all around london was my patch
for quite a long time and then yeah so
what would you say have been the main
nuances that you've maybe had to
adapt or maybe learn the hard way like
quite quite quickly once you started to
go into the u.s yeah i think it's well
to be quite honest i mean the roles that
we've actually just been working on have
been very similar roles to the ones that
i've been doing anyway i don't actually
i suppose it's just a time difference
it's obviously making sure that you know
you're setting up your calls at the
right times and but yeah i mean there
hasn't been tons of challenges i'd
really probably say obviously a lot of
people say
perception of recruitment's more
positive there yeah massively yeah i
mean you know everybody's very
respectful you know the fees are like
hugely higher you know the salaries are
so much higher you know there's a lot of
you know benefits to working in the us
and yeah it's a very respected industry
there as well which is obviously great
and what about how some people might
just perceive this as a challenge but it
probably isn't but how like how these
people reacted to getting on the phone
to nikki from manchester they're like
hanging out what's going on here like
what's that been like or is it actually
going to happen absolutely
yeah i think we market ourselves as uk
and us
so you know i think that definitely does
help um you know when you're actually
going out and you're trying to get your
candidate attraction but yeah it's been
absolutely fantastic you know people get
back to you so quickly yeah so i mean
it's been a great it's like a lot a lot
of the things that have always worked
for you the habits the approach
is completely translated over yeah i
mean to be fair it's just projects that
you just get done you just send out your
messages just make sure you're
attracting the right people you know you
just want to make sure that you're going
for the right tax tax and you can see
that that's going to be you know a
decent chris change or something that
would be interesting to them and yeah
it's just been yeah it's been a good
experience and have you have you focused
on because obviously it's such a big
place isn't it so like yeah it seemed
quite organic
atlanta and the other place but like
have you have you after you've done a
bit of it have you then been like right
we're just going to focus on this state
or i don't know how have you approached
that out of interest at this stage now
we have done a bit of research into
where we actually want to focus our kind
of bd efforts let's say the reason i
worked in those areas is that just you
know that's what my client needed them
yeah but we have actually been spending
quite a lot of time now i think right
this is going to be where mirai will
focus um and really have a look at the
data i think as well to just see what
sort of things are you looking for out
of interest like to go you know what
that that could be a really exciting
opportunity what sort of things are you
keeping an eye on looking at people
looking for like scale-up companies yeah
where investment's been made um and yeah
looking to provide like talent solutions
to people so you really kind of you know
go in and ring fence like a whole
company's business rather than rather
than like one two three yeah exactly
like where there's a shift you know
there's certain areas like texas but
we're getting on a little bit later than
that yeah so where's the new hot plate
yeah we can go and make an impact
it's exciting so let's let's talk about
the the rebrand and
like these types of things so like why
why was that important to do i've been
translated mirai tech before
like because obviously i've seen it all
now and like i don't know one why did
why why did you feel that was important
to do
two what was the process like and then
like free how has it been received and
stuff so like why was it important today
do you think i think because you know at
the start website is important but
you're not going to throw a load of
money at it yeah and also who who is
mirai yeah you know we could put a load
of words on there but we didn't have a
mission values we didn't really know our
story yeah and as we've progressed you
know we look at that the old website
like who who wrote that because it
wasn't
yeah it didn't represent us and even the
way we communicated our tone was a bit
corporate for whatever reason we're used
to speaking in a certain way but really
we just wanted to share our
personalities our journey you know we're
not perfect and kind of we want to be
quite humble in our approach as well
that we want to get there we're not
there yet but this is where we are so
far and we know who we are what we want
to do as well and how is it how it's
been received in the market then like
because i've spent all year i mean we're
more like do you like
yeah
do you like the pastel colors yeah so
people are getting actually going to say
yes yeah it's early days but yeah we've
had a lot of nice comments yeah yeah we
have and as part of this process being
i'm not sure but as part of this process
has been looking at your solutions and
the
services yeah that was a big part of it
because we're all fed up of no placement
no fee yeah whoever said that line you
know has got a lot to answer because
that's not what we're about actually
yeah why should we work
so hard with ultimately you could gain
nothing from it yeah
so really it's a full solution depending
on multi-hierarchy higher contract
solution from start to finish
and really provide that full service as
opposed to transactional bums on seats
there's one person one off yeah exactly
that so let's talk a bit more about this
because i i there from all the
conversation that i'm having i feel like
a modern day recruitment business
shouldn't just be going into a client or
customer and going yeah this is our
service it's like let's agree the fee
and then you pay me when on i don't
think that should be the only the only
thing that you're able to talk to them
about
so so you just said there so you've got
what how did you describe so you've got
a contract solution you've got
um that's more cost effective because
there are companies we've
placed about 30 people in you know so to
pay a fee 30 times yeah exactly so let's
look at your year yeah how many hires do
you think you're going to make right
okay well if we work on them exclusively
we can offer you this and it makes more
sense because why do you want to be
speaking to a number of different
recruiters just have that kind of what
becomes in-house almost support yeah and
it works better for us the consultants
and our clients as well so what's been
the main what's been the main difference
if any in terms of like
how approaching like selling this and
and um yeah or getting clients to sign
up to because i don't know is there a
different mindset of like approach and
the way that you're talking about things
because a lot of people had people sit
down and say
like the the best recruiters now have
got to be solutions focus so back to
your point everyone like understanding
where they're going the challenges and
those things and coming up with well
because of what you shared with me let's
talk about our the the solution that you
just said so we can actually help you
over the long run rather than just
paying an individual fee for yeah have
you noticed like a i don't know
different mindset towards the sales
conversation i don't know anything
around that obviously we were kind of
doing it before anyway without labeling
it so we provide
you know advertising campaigns salary
insight benchmarking feedback loop all
these things
and we value our time and our
consultants time
and you know we're lucky to work with
some great businesses but we've all been
there we've put so much time in had four
final stages somewhere and then they
changed their mind yeah and you're like
are you kidding you know so really it's
respect for our time as well but also
knowing that we're ultimately going to
do a good job
so how have you typically like the
commercials then have you have you gone
down like the retained route have you
gone down like a monthly subscription i
don't know how is that typical i'm sure
it's different for different companies
but how have you fought about that how's
that playing out yeah retained that's
what we're looking at yeah
dividing into three payments yeah
okay nice
so let's just talk a bit about before we
sort of come to the end and finish then
so how you said at the beginning like
what's really important to you and
things that would be different is like
the people part so let's just talk a bit
about that so how how have you thought
about uh because you haven't had to do
this before like how have you fought
about and gone about building your
culture out of interest
yeah i mean i think culture's a massive
part for us you know i think we kind of
summed it up we didn't want anyone to
ever experience that sunday fear of
coming into work ever again you know
like we want to make sure we've got an
environment where people feel really
supported you know you can speak to
anyone on all levels no questions should
you know ever be deemed to be silly you
know and we just want somewhere where
people feel like adults they can be
ambitious but you know everyone's got
their own types of personalities and we
can you know mold them all together
really yeah and we want to lead with
compassion not fair yeah and united
style recruitment is like hitting you
over their head kpis
no one feels good you know you've got to
be compassionate especially today
understanding rolling it together we
want to perform well we want to earn
well but you don't have to act with you
know lead with fear to achieve those
results there's different ways to get
the best out of people yeah so is it and
has there been anything i guess is a bit
granular anything like specific that
you've done that's really worked on
cultivating this culture and and not
leaving them with other knows there are
things that you do on a monthly basis
with your team that that you've found
really helps with other than anything
that we do quite a lot of like the team
building so it's not just about like i
think we speak before about like the
busy culture that can be associated with
recruitment you know like we'll go on
nice light team walks we do like little
walks and talks you know like once a
week we'll you know go out with somebody
that's on our team and just talk about
stuff that isn't about recruitment and
you know it's like how are you getting
on like what's going on in your life
yeah you know and just make sure that
you on a personal level that you can
actually speak to people and they feel
comfortable to talk you know to the
managers about you know just normal
day-to-day life as well yeah and we've
started investing in well-being
workshops yeah
the guys they love it really yeah really
loving it's early days with that and but
that what sort of things are you getting
people to speak about is it just just
mental health as a whole is it like talk
to them about things i don't know habits
that they could be thinking about that
could help them yeah outside of work
yeah so it's building resilience
being a thought and there's another one
it's about being kind to yourself as
well and you know really having those
conversations that i i've never had so
we've started individual therapy with
the same doctor
and she now is doing the workshops with
the guys that we're part of yeah and
it's just like oh my god it's just good
to talk isn't it yeah and you're not
alone and you often there is a tendency
to think you're the only one feeling
certain ways yeah like everyone feels
the same so how how how like what what
are people like how why has that helped
them and has it have they gone emma
thanks so much for this like i haven't
had this before it's been great to speak
about things like what have you how have
they why have they reacted so positively
do you think what have they shared with
you i think because we all do have our
struggles don't we internally and people
aren't often okay with talking about
them or raising those subjects like they
said thinking they're alone with it yeah
and when she just talks about the
science behind it as well so there's a
reason you feel like this this is what's
going on in your brain and it's like oh
it's a huge education piece around there
because you can think we can think like
oh is it just me that's wired this way
or like things this way but when you
learn about these things like oh no
we're actually all why this way yeah
yeah yeah
go and get some fresh air you know take
a break because they don't do that
enough and we're guilty of just like
sitting at the screen but we all need a
bit of fresh air and yeah yeah just
breathing we just breathing exercises we
did indeed
you know what they've really worked
i love that so what what what have been
some of the the maybe challenges and
things you've both had to work through
on this journey so far then that maybe
you've you least expected to have to
deal with that's a good question i think
our strength is also our weakness
because we take action quickly yeah and
we get over excited okay let's hire
loads of people right now do we have
systems in place
so let's do it anyway yeah and mark was
funny though because he does let us make
our own mistakes he guides us but it's
like i think you were hiring a little
bit early or so i think people has been
tough for us yeah because we were over
excited with that without building the
foundations yeah so we hired too quickly
and too many too many yeah you've got to
get your yeah building machine isn't it
and then you're offering
let's just talk about that for a second
before we finish like
when you say that like what do you mean
in terms of like the the foundations or
processes what like what do you actually
mean by that it's even just getting like
your tech stack down and like your
processes in terms of appraisals you
know there's so much stuff that you need
to think about um you know like the
people's day-to-day
yeah but yeah i think um a lot of the
stuff it's just making sure that you've
got all of that kind of foundation
sorted job roles like what they're going
to be targeting at like what patches
that they're going to be looking at you
know they're going to be great on bd are
they going to be great on delivery you
know there's a lot of different things
to it
and there is an element of winging it
when you're in startup yeah but then
there is like we're going to do a
development review
we don't have any people that's a good
point we're gonna talk about yeah okay
let's go and have a chat yeah
you know and these things and that adds
stress to us because you're like oh my
god i need to do that i need to and
we're spreading ourselves too thin
ultimately yeah you know and now we're
trying to take a step back go slower to
go quicker yeah exactly yeah go slower
to go quicker yeah
okay
it's working
so where are you as a business today
then like how many of you are there and
you're eight now yeah yeah yeah and the
plan is hopefully to be at about
15 to 20 but by the end of the year but
it's not the be all in there and we're
learning about that has that maybe been
the learning for both of you yeah
like we're going to have hundreds of
people all over the globe it's gonna be
great yeah we're quite ambitious i
suppose we did have quite grand pumps
when we started really yeah
well like well it can be quite easy to
like fall into that though can't yeah
sure like that way of thinking
why do you think that is because it is
very common you just think the more
people you have the more successful
you're going to be but really what you
have to do is invest in the people that
you've got to say that we didn't but you
know what you mean but that's even the
processes and make sure they've got
everything they need not just and then
they need to be billing and then you add
more to the you know through the fire
you know and that's the whole point
isn't it but yeah if you've got like six
trainees and then two of you you know
you are spread things so yeah so someone
listen to this and that might be in that
startup here that's like i do want to
hire i'm not sure if like what would
what would you say it should be like the
fundamentals that maybe they should
think about that they have in place
that should hopefully give them a better
chance of these hires going well rather
than maybe not working out three six
months down the line what would you what
advice would you give them i mean i
think if you've got the jobs on one or
two is absolutely fine but make sure
they're okay and comfortable before you
then add to it yeah because we just kept
adding when the other team members were
still fairly junior
yeah
or we all want to try and get seniors on
board but that is impossible that's
tough as well
yeah that is tough so so to to finish
this up then like what um
where where's mariah going to be the
mirai talents or is it going to be in in
another year two years time what's
what's the ambition in the u.s yeah we'd
love to see at least business coming
from the us yeah and also contract
home split 50 50 as well absolutely yeah
and you're thinking
are you planning on getting people over
there are you giving them absolutely
yeah
i volunteer definitely first plane
ticket yeah yeah absolutely love that
well um look absolute pleasure having
both of you on thank you so much for
coming down and i'm so excited to see
where both of you are in another year
two years time thank you
thank you so much for listening to the
episode i hope you enjoyed it and got
value from the conversation if you did
enjoy it please don't forget to like
share and subscribe and we'll see you in
the next episode